[Musica]
[Applauso]
questo questo Talk si chiama
stopble e in particolare parla di
empowerment femminile Poi cercheremo di
spiegare meglio cos'è l'empowerment
femminile ma non solo si rivolge a tutti
uomini e donne quindi senza distinzione
di genere a tutti i colori quali si
battono per la lotta contro il
discriminazioni e per affermare il
valore dell'unicità
vedete ho scritto cosa imparare cosa ho
imparato in particolare durante il mio
percorso
personale e professionale e soprattutto
cosa ho disimparato è molto importante a
prendere ma anche importante quello che
tu apprendi di non dover più fare e
quindi molti sono anche maestri nel
farti vedere cosa tu vorresti non fare
L'ho chiamato un stop vuol titolo di
questa Tolkien stopble è un attributo al
quale sono molto affezionata un
attributo che appunto è la il Magazine
startup Italia quindi nella rivista
start up Italia mi ha dato per il quarto
anno consecutivo inserendomi tra le un
stop volumen le mille italiane che
stanno cambiando il mondo e sono fiera
di essere unstoppable iniziamo
questo percorso
Questo è il 1984 è l'inizio poco più che
ventenne
giovanissima ricercatrice vinco una
borsa di studio per gli Stati Uniti per
Manhattan alla New York University era
il mio sogno era il mito degli anni 80 a
New York The Big Apple felice sarei
andata a studiare Le startup
Passione e amore che avrei dedicato per
tutta la vita perché Le startup sono il
cambiamento sono la creazione di nuovi
scenari appunto sono l'innovazione e
quindi ero in un gruppo di ricerca e un
gruppo internazionale composta da
giapponesi appunto americani cinesi
tedeschi Greci unica italiana mi
presento ciascuno di noi si doveva
presentare e inizio My name is e Carmela
ma gli amici mi chiamano Elita
Sono sposata
ma sono senza marito in questo momento
devo studiare qui Come fare business
vengo dalla Sicilia mi guardano il gelo
Married
Sicily business mafia ho sentito tutto
addosso Mi sono sentita proprio non so
se qualcuno ha visto questo bellissimo
film La ragazza con la pistola di Mario
Monicelli dove c'era una splendida
Monica Vitti è una storia di
emancipazione femminile Lei arriva in
Inghilterra ecco E allora tutta la somma
dei pregiudizi mi è calata Addosso ho
detto devo combattere contro questi
pregiudizi e l'ho fatto e avrei
combattuto una vita intera e non sono
sola non sono stata sola sono tantissime
sono migliaia le donne straordinarie
uomini che ho incontrato che combattono
con contro i pregiudizi quindi non sono
solo storie isolate ma siamo in tanti
siamo moltissimi E tutto questo per
batterci contro le discriminazioni come
dicevo mi piace citare anche questo
libro si chiama centomila punture di
Spillo ed è un libro che è stato scritto
da Carlo De Benedetti suggerito Rampini
circa vent'anni fa e diceva questo per
il cambiamento dobbiamo essere tutti
dobbiamo essere in tanti dobbiamo
contagiarci dobbiamo contaminarci
dobbiamo trasferirci energia non
dobbiamo pensare Non si fa questo non si
fa quello ma dobbiamo essere sempre
propositivi Ebbene Questo è il mio
pensiero dobbiamo sempre pensare che è
possibile cambiare che possiamo
costruire nuovi scenari ed è importante
farlo ora è importante farlo in questo
momento Perché in questo momento è il
momento in cui si sta creando un
amplificazione delle diseguaglianze e
delle discriminazioni Questo è un
momento centrale perché sono aumentate
le diseguaglianze le discriminazioni
dopo la pandemia che come sapete si è
trasformato in sintonia sono aumentate
le povertà sono aumentate le
diseguaglianze alimentari sono aumentate
le diseguaglianze digitali è un mondo
che sta contrastando le catastrofi
ambientali questo momento è un momento
in cui abbiamo abbiamo bisogno di unirci
appunto 100.000 punture di Spillo tutti
insieme per promuovere il cambiamento
abbiamo urgenza di cambiamento e voglio
citare le parole di questa splendida
afroamericana attivista Kimberly
screenshot che parlava già nel 1989 di
femminismo intersezionale e così
cerchiamo di capire vi spiego un attimo
Che cos'è il femminismo intersezionale
vuole dire che non c'è nel mondo solo un
problema di
discriminazione Uomini e Donne e
problema che chiaramente viene vissuta
in modo diverso Ma pensate cosa stanno
facendo le donne dell'Iran pensate alla
forza il coraggio di tante donne che
lottano per i loro vittime per i diritti
civili non c'è un problema di
discriminazione solo uomini e donne ma
c'è un problema appunto Ricordiamoci di
discriminazioni di razza c'è un problema
di discriminazione di religione c'è un
problema di discriminazione di status
sociale ci sono problemi discriminazione
legati all'orientamento sessuale e così
via dicendo questi problemi
discriminazione si sommano l'uno
all'altro una sorta di overlapping e
fanno da effetto Prisma quindi c'è
l'urgenza di lottare in questo momento
proprio in questo momento non si può
stare fermi perché su questi temi o si
va avanti o si torna indietro e voglio
ricordare anche perché in questo momento
e gli addetti ai lavori sanno che in
questo momento si parla di isg che
sarebbero environment Social e
governance cioè sono stati emanati dei
regolamenti dall'Unione Europea dirette
a promuoverla sostenibilità ambientale
ed è importantissima la sostenibilità
ambientale ma non solo la sostenibilità
sociale quindi la prima è environment S
sarebbe Social e g governance occorre
promuovere un nuovo govern una
governance per esempio che preveda le
donne e al vertice delle strutture delle
strutture imprenditoriali delle
strutture istituzionali quindi in questo
momento in cui si parla di Rating isg
questi temi sono attualissimi E allora
cosa si può fare come vi dicevo
all'inizio cosa penso dal mio punto di
vista si possa fare in primo luogo
dobbiamo colmare il gender data Gap sono
pochissimi ancora anche se ci sembra che
non sia così sono pochissimi ancora i
dati sulle donne sulle discriminazioni
femminili c'è un bellissimo libro che
citerò anche dopo che si chiama
invisibili e questo libro parla del
fatto che le donne i dati sulle donne
sono assenti nella cultura sono assenti
Nella medicina sta cominciando a parlare
di medicina di genere sono assenti nelle
arti nelle professioni nella musica
quindi le donne e i loro dati sono
invisibili quindi prima di tutto in
tutti ricercatori dobbiamo colmare il
vuoto di dati ma poi ci sono due
direzioni due due percorsi che sono
Secondo me assolutamente intrecciati
l'uno con l'altro il primo percorso è
quello di lavorare sulle empowerment
questa parola no c'è la valorizzazione
di se stessi e sapere di valere io valgo
e questo si può fare chiaramente con un
percorso in cui ciascuno riprende a
fiducia in se stesso nella bellezza come
dicevo prima della propria unicità della
propria diversità e il secondo è il
secondo livello di azione e lavorare su
strategie inclusive Queste sono
strategie sono percorsi decisionali cioè
sono decisioni che le aziende devono
prendere per migliorare accelerare il
processo di inserimento delle donne e di
tutte le altre comunità discriminate
all'interno per esempio
dell'organizzazione lavorative e del
resto Voi sapete che in moltissime
aziende Sta entrando la funzione che si
chiama
proprio per creare i presupposti anche
organizzativi Affinché si possono fare
politiche di eguaglianza all'interno
delle organizzazioni aziendali Adesso vi
parlerò di quello che ho imparato e
quindi vi dicevo per unire questi due
percorsi da un lato di empowerment e
dall'altro di strategie appunto di
inclusione Io ho pensato di sintetizzare
il mio pensiero e in 7 punti 7 pillars
Secondo me è importanti e che
rappresentano come diceva All'inizio le
storie di tantissimi donne e tantissime
donne e tantissimi uomini che lottano
contro le discriminazioni e quindi le ho
sintetizzati in 7 punti così ce lo
ricordiamo no e anche diciamo questo 7 è
un numero che ricorre molte volte il
primo elemento to be the first essere la
prima no In molti casi Quella è la prima
donna e quasi come un trofeo io sono
stata la prima una presa in Sicilia tra
le pochissime ordinarie in Management
molto spesso la prima il primo
amministratore delegato e di incubatore
eccetera e all'inizio questa cosa mi
faceva piacere però poi il tema non è
essere le prime ma il tema è Non
rinunciare non rinunciare a colmare
sempre nuove ambizioni a creare nuove
scenari Allora io dico a tutti e a tutte
siate ambiziosi dove l'ambizione non è
un elemento negativo no ci hanno
abituato a pensare all'ambizione come un
elemento negativo ma l'ambizione e la
capacità di aprire le proprie ali e di
superare il proprio ambito se di volare
verso scenari diversi quindi il primo
elemento to be first è vero siamo è
proprio questo oppure piuttosto non
rinunciare a volare il secondo elemento
è appunto parlavo di non rinunciare a
volare a creare il piacere di creare mi
piaceva creare mi sono messa a creare ho
creato l'incubatore universitario e il
consorzio è tutta una serie di attività
e poi da ultimo durante la pandemia è un
dipartimento intero universitario
sull'innovazione nel campo e l'elcare
era un piacere creare insieme a tante
persone bellissimo il pensiero di creare
insieme però ogni volta che creavo che
creavamo c'era sempre qualcuno che
voleva distruggere voleva distruggere o
perché semplicemente non ci aveva
pensato oppure perché era invidioso
oppure magari perché avevo detto troppi
no e quindi era diciamo infastidito
dalla nuova iniziativa una volta un
prestito un reattore mi disse tu sei un
Caterpillar taglia firmare Allora il
piacere di creare ma allo stesso tempo
ho scoperto che poi c'è sofferenza
quando appunto crei la tua creatura Vedi
che la tua creatura è lì e qualcuno Poi
te la vuole togliere ma ciò che ho
imparato è che l'importante a creare e
poi quello che tu hai fatto deve
diventare patrimonio di tutti e C'è
troppa sofferenza prima nel tenere poi
nell'aspettare che qualcuno ti voglia
levare poi per combattere ho visto gente
tenuta stretta la propria sedia e
prestiti che non volevano mollare la
propria sede per 30 anni
sindaci che non amministratori delegati
che non vogliono fare il cambiamento
generazionale Ecco invece è così bello
appunto creare forme di attaccamento al
potere diverse da quelle gerarchiche
quelle diciamo alle quali Siamo
purtroppo ancora legati terzo elemento
l'ho chiamato il condizionamento della
modestia e
contrariamente a quello che si crede le
donne sono molto modeste e credono di
valere meno credono di valere meno di
quello che valgono E infatti c'è un
problema di gender pay-up cioè c'è una
differenza retributiva in moltissimi
paesi che partire dal 25 al 30% le donne
con lo stesso merito degli uomini
vengono pagate di meno chiaramente
questo è contro il merito e hanno la
possibilità di avanzamenti di carriera
molto più lenti di quella degli uomini e
questo è un po' è legato forse al fatto
che non si auto per vongole o con con
negoziano poco quindi è importante è
importante saper chiedere il valore di
ciò che meritiamo quarto punto abuso di
perdono questa parola questa espressione
l'ho presa in prestito da un bellissimo
film che ho visto qualche settimana fa
Women Talking nell'ambito i premi Oscar
e di appunto di quest'anno del 2023 in
cui le donne una comunità femminile le
protagoniste E abusate dai loro uomini
sia
emozionalmente sia fisicamente dicono
forse il nostro è stato un eccesso un
abuso di perdono e quindi bisogna stare
attenti a dire dico sempre Va bene va
bene così ma ci deve essere un limite in
quell'ottica appunto di rispetto della
propria dignità e allora voglio
ricordare un incipit con cui questo
bellissimo libro che ci dava prima che
si chiama invisibili libro di Carolina
creato Perez che dice perché le donne
sono invisibili e che ha vinto il premio
come migliore business book dell'anno
da parte del Financial Times e da parte
di makings questo incipit iniziale che
dice alle donne che non mollano siate
sempre maledettamente difficili e passo
col Quinto punto Quinto punto che è la
ridefinizione dell'idea di successo Che
cos'è il successo per la donna o
comunque per quella serie di appunto
comunità che non sono nell'ambito del
paradigma classico cos'è l'idea di
successo per la donna e soprattutto Che
cosa significa quelle scelte che non
sono scelte ma che siamo obbligate a
fare
E allora con riferimento a quest'ultimo
punto molte volte le donne si auto
escludono non perché non abbiano le
capacità le caratteristiche Ma perché ci
sono dei percorsi che le auto che ne
escludono le escludono Perché le donne
devono chiaramente creare forme di
valorizzazione contemporanea del lavoro
di cura a casa del Lavoro negli ambienti
organizzativi quindi necessariamente
tante volte e sono obbligate a
rinunciare a dei percorsi ma soprattutto
la cosa più importante per me Qual è
l'idea del successo per la donna punto
all'idea del successo non è quella dei
parametri economico finanziari No non
valutiamo sulla base diciamo di ciò che
mettiamo in tasca ma l'idea del successo
e della nonna è quella di mantenere i
propri ambiti di libertà e di autonomia
e dire anche io sono autentica con me
stessa col mio percorso di vita
personale e col mio percorso di vita
professionale vado al sesto punto Il
marketing sbagliato molte volte mi sono
sentita dire Ah Ma tu sei troppo giovane
per questa cosa no no Ma tu sei troppo
giovane come dicevo prima sei
scalpitante sei qui oppure no Ma adesso
sei troppo in là No ero sempre troppo ma
ero sempre fuori non c'era il timing
Giusto Allora io ho capito che non c'è
mai nel timing giusto nel timing
sbagliato c'è il timing delle cose che
ami fare è quello quello è il momento
giusto e ho imparato anche che una forma
di antifragilità non vergognarsi delle
proprie emozioni
infine l'ultimo punto la bellezza di
fare strada alle tante come dicevo prima
siamo moltissime Siamo tantissime storie
straordinarie di donne che vogliono
combattere il luogo comune Le donne sono
le peggiori nemiche di se stesso Non è
vero Non è vero questo me sento dire
ogni mamma ma non è assolutamente vero
Anzi io ho scoperto nel mio cammino la
bellezza delle sorellanza e ho imparato
che l'unica vera forma sostenibile
competizione è quella Win Win e quindi
arriviamo insieme arriviamo insieme
perché la vittoria di ciascuno perché la
vittoria era stata di ciascuna è la
vittoria di tutti e voglio lasciarvi con
questo bellissimo video che un video che
è stato preparato per la giornata
internazionale della donna di quest'anno
8 marzo 2023 e che un video in cui
sentirete a un certo punto una delle
ragazze che dice I don't
Io non voglio fare la storia I don't
want to be the only woman io non voglio
essere l'unica donna I want to be one of
many be one of Man siamo tutti parte di
questa grande collettività che lotta per
il cambiamento lotta per le mutazioni e
quindi fiera di essere appunto un
stopball Sentiamoci il video
only Human
I want to be one of many
[Musica]